hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we got a
little shooting range here and it gave
me a reward for finishing it it was just
a um a small one but I'm hoping that yep
infinite bullets
oh you look blue I'm guessing doing
civilian no I'm not gonna shoot you no
matter how hard you want me to pop pop
pop man the mouse controls are not gonna
help me with this oh no I don't know how
I magically have infinite bullet
plaid because otherwise wouldn't be
worth it hop boom pop boom I win all
right
I wonder how many levels there are bet I
can win them all that's it come on give
me something better three ever three up
in yah no you're not an enemy up you are
you're not cut problematic Isaac kind of
standing right in the way nope huh huh
oh I know I'm not going for headshots
bones try to get maximize my chance of
winning here stop judging me Oh ho-ho
frou frou frou nope not pro not pro bro
Oh
MLG open yah Oh someone's gonna recruit
me when I see this video ah that's more
like it
that's worth money alright go again I'm
gonna go all the way level four yeah
that was stupid haha alright I fail
right off the bat I got ya I still got
it [ __ ] there you are
hiding behind us I know
I'm feeling I fail I fail damn it I'm
bad okay
big surprise I'm bad I'm bad at this
I'll give another try but even if I
don't win it this one I'm just gonna be
cuz I got a ship to save and why would I
stop to try out a shooting range got all
up Oh got ya ha Gaia Gaia Gaia ah ah
nope ha ha ah come on
right at the end ah all right that's all
I'm gonna try on that one sorry to waste
everybody's time with my failure all
right moving on what Wow
yet you you I'm good fuse did you rip
off your own leg did a monster come by
and slice off your leg and leave you
alone why we and why would you just hold
it as if you're gonna Oh eat a dog or
something I don't know why don't you
hold it like that weird whoa hello oh
good job
let's sit large medpac oh hang on hope
you got here I need to use a med pack
get your camera up there all right I
didn't quite do it so stuff my face with
another one there we go
not that I ever need to make these mud
packs alright anything else that guy
doesn't look so good oops sorry about
your head bro okay so don't go through
the lasers
oh stasis okay well ice froze it in the
wrong spot
hi nice whoa hello okay good job there
you didn't follow your friend's advice
alright I gotta wait for it to go back
there we go alright there sky sky mine
and this is mine as well give me give it
give it get it get you star but I don't
even understand why you're so stupid
are you joking me there huh
things be acting stupid what's that
that's nothing it's nothing
ah where where where where where where
where - there nope nope not today
you're not dead
that's good it's really good yeah no
such a bad shot
honed what the hell what no don't get
really you take that moment to save and
their explody booze around alright sound
here
hello dead guy power note yep
give it up alright
okay got that not saving don't need to
save gimme Oh screw the med pack Oh care
do not care how I'm doing the right way
I don't need to know anymore I feel like
I'm just going into big circle obviously
not considering this room I don't like
this room so it's like the type of room
to launch a lot of enemies at you from a
distance ah
huh whoa where you come from
oh it's watching oh don't do that don't
do that babies now your babies baby baby
baby
did you actually unlaunchable ones I
don't see any I know
ah best one hey come on die go
not today I see you down there no oh
what's up hi
yeah you're done here die die die there
you go nope I'm dead
all right more pork wanna mess up no
boom Oh bro nope not today
hey come back here no no no you're not
dead
there you go and you go load boom like
that it sure is easy when they're all on
the other side of the room I need some
ammo like badly ha who did that
get dead
okay here we go more Emma lockdown
Wow geez thank you for locking them in
with me always appreciate the help of
the computer whatever
I'm not spiteful where am I going
what's in here I don't know yeah maybe
some goodies pile of rubble my favorite
goodie
yeh dhoop to do making my way down the
hallway inventory full full of what all
right look I got here point
eyes only priority black objective deep
cleanse I love that deep cleansing
action they are believed to have
recovered marker 3a Special Ops has
confirmed the system but has been unable
to provide planet location special ops
advises caution if marker 3a has been
recovered infection by a lethal organism
is a credible threat so they should have
known shock point agus system moved to
position out of local scope range and
wait signal from Ishimura to confirm
location so they should have known I
have no pity I have no pity for these
soldiers not a bit gotta offload a bunch
of stuff I am full to capacity
yes large med pack I got so many mediums
Gold yeah here yeah here okay now keep
it plain fuel or synergy out of here I
need some more bullet holes rounds damn
it and powder because why not I just
spent like nine power notes in that and
back up to seven they're raining from
the sky any feels I don't see anything
else oh wait no there's a box I didn't
open
hello give me that all right we're good
we good can we move out now all right
let's move on well Oh almost touch that
don't touch that I've seen what happens
you die or you get plastered to the
ceiling and you just stay there
most likely death what oh just like that
guy I went all that way just to get to
the other side of that geez well well I
don't I know what
what's that what's that oh no whatever
II was he was scared of me didn't come
face me just ran away like little baby
whoo awesome hmm huh wha what's that
oh nothing hey yeah that's right run
away little girl I could have helped you
but whatever don't matter
that's what happened all these soldiers
are cowards man any of my watchers are
military men or women okay guys all
right where did he go
Oh
flashy screaming night okay there's
something coming from the other side of
there or it is it big and I'm gonna
fight it
Oh what is that I don't know okay um
do-do-do-do-do-do gimme gimme all right
um yep up we go why not
look hey oh hello hello fire the hell
okay this don't look good
okay I get a blister
move behind them okay here we go
what the hell now
man what kind of ship design is this
this does not seem like efficient ship
design to me what do I know I'm just an
engineer
okay let's shoot these
haha down behind it what the hell what
right behind it but Loney okay can I
just shoot it from here
is there another one go all the way
did I get it I don't see anymore
I got God the hell screw this I'm what
the hell can't even pull it back with me
oh come on such a whip Isaac suck it up
and deal
okay and pull back we go ah screw it I'm
just it's great I'm running running I
can make it I can make it I can make it
on you man
yeah I made it alright so maybe there
I'm guessing there others on this side
yeah there are ah I don't get you far
away this can't be how normal
maintenance is done on this ship
actually no it must be our normal
maintenance instead of the ship these
ass-backwards people can't even fight
come on let me get it let me get it did
that do it
okay there we go what a
Hecky heck I mean my goodness
ah singularity core that's what I can
whoa what the hell whoa you got oh my
god yeah I did yes I did baby we need
get to the crew deck you're welcome good
thing you didn't do anything you didn't
thank me
what the hell lady ungrateful woman you
guys are grateful right aren't you
I hope so but I got a card in here thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye-bye